was that acting was that overdoing it in
Hollywood style with him talking to the
branch not at all
I'm embarrassed as to how many times
I've talked to a tree or a branch or a
rock and don't you effing break yeah
that's exactly what I'd be saying hey GQ
I'm les trout and welcome back to part
two we're gonna be looking at more
jungle survival scenes this is the
breakdown
[Music]
all right let's check out another scene
from the movie jungle
[Applause]
so what we have here is hallucination
I'd be hallucinating too and the reality
is that when it comes to hallucination
it doesn't take long it starts with your
dreams you want to have great dreams
don't eat today the dreams are intense
this is how indigenous cultures would
have vision quests they would not eat or
drink and then the dreams would be
insane well when you go this long like
y'all see has those dreams become strong
while you're awake if you start being
unable to differentiate between I'm
asleep and dreaming and I'm awake and
this is reality
how probable is it for Yossi to just
walk through the jungle and stumble into
some quick Stan it is very probable
again he's hallucinating he's exhausted
starving thirsty the vision goes fuzzy
and you can walk into just about
anything with everything else that
happened to him I'm amazed he didn't
just bump into a big old hornet's nest
in the jungle and they are nasty good
little move there you get into a
situation like quicksand get the
backpack off anything that's going to
hold you down take it off try to get it
away if you're wearing a hat just throw
it you know get get stuff off because
everything that is attached to you is
going to be a hindrance and is going to
work against you in trying to get out of
the mud
[Music]
a little bit of acting going on here as
far as the reach out to get his passport
it's a little bit of acting I mean he
could have just sloshed and gotten it
good thing he didn't though here's the
problem with quicksand every movement
you make serves to make you sink down so
just making big moves with your legs
which you want to do because you're
panicking will actually take your neck
your head and start to sink you lower
into the mud very dangerous and again
when it comes to hallucinating
remember just moments ago he was
hallucinating and now he's in the mud
and even though that reality is going to
wake him out of it he's so exhausted
that he's going to drift back into it I
think old Tarzan movies gave the
impression that quicksand is like
sentient and was working to pull you
down no it's just physiologically
speaking it works to pull you down the
movements you make make force your body
to go down deeper but it's not like
quicksand is sitting there like some
kind of carnivorous plant waiting for a
human to happen into it so it can grab
it and pull you down that's not what's
going on here they don't even tell you
how long he was out for and he's
probably passed out and slipped in and
out of his SaLuSa Nations it's actually
a good thing the thing that I push
probably most for in a survival
situation over many other things is
sleep is getting rest without rest
without I mean this is how you can be
tortured this is how you can be trained
in the military go without sleep mostly
going without sleep is a mental state of
torture that I I don't like it when I
have to have been in those situations in
the jungle or the desert or somewhere
else
in a survival situation no sleep it's
really torturous but any sleep that you
can get will give you that moment of
energy to get out of the situation
that's what's happening here
okay so that's the proverbial all a
branch that the jungle is kind of
putting out for him to grab on to
it's tricky reaching for branches and
leaves they break they split they pull
out and so getting as you'd say you know
it's like getting solid footing but
getting a solid grab his stuff and in a
situation like this it's almost the only
thing that's going to get him out being
active and busy will force his body down
the idea is to try to get as flat as
possible all the time
laying there is you're not going to just
float to the surface but you're going to
stabilize and really at that point it's
about your mind and manipulating your
muscles your legs your arms your fingers
so you can actually picture the way your
body is and think about the manoeuvre
out you can't at this point he's relaxed
enough to notice if he reaches out a
little bit he can grab this leaf that's
the right way to do it you can't just
grab and pull you have to get enough of
a hold on that branch that that leaf is
not going to rip and so twisting and
twisting pulling and twisting as he
pulls all of that is giving him stronger
and stronger grab as he goes until he
can get to the stronger part of the
branch
branch like that absolutely can be
strong enough to use to pull yourself
out of a mud hole like that in fact
there are very very thin strands in the
jungle then thinner than my baby finger
that are super strong so not knowing the
species of the tree and all of that
notwithstanding the reality is that the
thickness of the branch is not
necessarily going to indicate how strong
it is and some of the thinnest vines in
the jungle are powerfully strong was
that acting was that overdoing it in
Hollywood style with him talking to the
branch not at all
I'm embarrassed as to how many times
I've talked to a tree or a branch or a
rock and in a desperate situation like
this don't you effing break yeah that's
exactly what I'd be saying
[Music]
his body's up a little bit high there
because he's in something they've made
in this you know they created he's not
in a real mud hole they've made this for
the sake of the movie so he he's getting
his elbow on a perch there it would have
been better if he was still sinking low
and pulling himself out truth of the
matter is in for the sake of the story
he's completely exhausted so pulling out
inch by inch is a reality they've done a
good job of realism of how it looks but
this last moment right here you know
he's basically already safe and there's
a little bit of play here like there's a
monster holding his foot that said there
is a ton of suction it's like in regular
water if you're wearing bigger rubber
boots it's hard to get out of the water
because the rubber boots fill with water
and then that suction kind of holds you
in the mud there is a suction there I
think they're just over playing it just
a little bit so much for the pack best
way out of a situation is to back away
right you get you go into a yard with a
bunch of mean guard dogs the best thing
to do is back away slowly because what's
behind you you already know about you
already know that what is behind you is
safe in the situation of a mud pit back
away you just walked on solid ground
that's where the solid ground is if you
go forward you don't know if it's 30
yards away before you see solid ground
again but in the Hollywood sense you
know they got to play the scene out a
little longer a little more dramatic so
it looks like he went for me I would
have gone backwards here's the thing
about Josi Ginsburg and his story in the
jungle
when I commented on his experience from
the perspective of a survival instructor
so I was a little cold-hearted about it
he gave me the best strongest most
powerful story of somebody who survived
by pure
we'll everything went wrong for him he
had no luck and luck is a component of
survival it's just there for you
sometimes he went through horrifying
mental anguish but he kept going forward
his will to live was one of the
strongest wills that I've ever learned
of in any survival situation
next up rescued on concept of somebody
not eating quote-unquote food in this
situation when you're really really
hungry that's a hard one for me to
accept because generally speaking I find
people go just a few days without food
and anything if someone says here eat
this you just do no matter how squeamish
you are I've never seen a survival
student maybe people I've taken out in
classes and that not eat what is
available no matter how much of a
creepy-crawly it is it could be alive it
could be dead it could have fangs and
could have claws that could look real
real bad I think that eating creepy
crawlies in a survival situation has
been played up so so badly in all of the
survival shows that are on television
it's just become this big melodramatic
moment when somebody's got to eat
something gross when the truth of a
survival situation is that you could eat
the wrong but if the impression is out
there that well a bug is just a bug it's
gross but it's good for survival not so
there are plenty of bugs that you can
eat that are poisonous and you should
not eat well let's take a look at a
scorpion scorpions are actually quite
tasty but you don't want to eat a
scorpion with the stingers
attached so there are there are some
nuances to eating creepy-crawlies
survival has been sensationalized on
television that there are bugs that
people eat alive and it's you know so
gross and and all of that and the
reality is most of them are much better
dead
I've eaten lots of scorpions and I've
eaten one live scorpion and that was
really more than anything kind of just
showmanship is just me say oh you can
you can eat it alive but if you can get
a fire going almost everything is better
roasted it comes down to survival as a
group that's something to remember
there's a big big difference between
solo survival dual survival or group
survival and the I will say this much
the the disadvantage of being solo
survival is you have no help for
anything obviously but the advantage is
that if you were to find something and
you're alone surviving it's all for you
to eat but in a group situation you have
to share like Lord of the Flies main
groups and and their dynamics it just
all falls apart as time goes on and the
thing about leadership that's really
intriguing is it can change and that
leaders been established through their
group activities long before the
survival situation we all know that's
the leader however when the survival
situation hits oftentimes that leader is
not the right person for the job in the
new situation and someone else rises to
the occasion this is a prisoner-of-war
situation nothing I'm familiar with but
the laws of survival still apply when
it's a group and jaw jockeying for
position of leadership is going to
happen before long absolutely and that's
of course what's happening here they're
starting to jockey for leadership
warden himself you know one way to have
done this would have been to say we all
need to eat this we all need to stay
alive we need to get our nutrition so
divide it the process of doing that of
of measuring out the mealy bugs and
worms
it actually takes it away from being
gross and disgusting and turns it into
food you ration until you get more and
then sometimes you can go great time to
pig out and eat a whole bunch of stuff
because there's lots but if you ration
and you never get any more then you're
doing the right thing this is also where
it gets real tricky in a survival
situation with a group because if
someone hoards food and they didn't or
they okay hot food and didn't share okay
next up
Romancing the Stone
okay it's makes it tough okay well
that's dramatic let's just throw our
survival pack over the cliff because
that's just a lot better to do that then
actually keep it on you yeah no you
never part yourself from your gear in a
survival situation you should have your
own path in a survival situation and you
should hold on to it so yeah sorry two
seconds into it and the characters
already blown it by throwing the pack
over the cliff okay I guess it was
motivation why she was able to fall that
fast
well that's called moviemaking nobody
falls that quickly without knowing it's
coming
well first of all could a mudslide go
for that fart absolutely
there are hillsides in the jungle that
go forever and once the rain starts
pouring down like that those little
mudslides do tend to erupt just about
everywhere now not to the point where
you just let that fall all of a sudden
like these guys did but if you were to
slip on one and start going downhill
this next part other than some bad
camera technique is actually kind of
sort of realistic big long mudslides in
the middle of the jungle and they're
that slippery so was it realistic that
they went down like that yeah kind of
was now that's actually kind of
realistic right there
jungle crazies adrenaline junkies
you know you get through something
that's like was horrifying and they're
like Yahoo why they call them Yahoo's it
yeah I know guys like that that's
probably the only time that I get like
that cuz I'm not an adrenaline junkie
but at the end of something that could
have killed you and you're standing
there alive if there's any time to
shriek for joy that's it
[Music]
I said are you hurt
that's comment on the rain first of all
does it rain like that that hard for
that long all the time
oh absolutely I've been in the jungle
before where I've washed it rain that
hard and harder for eight hours
without stopping and it can go longer
but I'll tell you how they get a
downpour like that well behind the
scenes moviemaking it is almost
impossible to film actual rain you have
to have these big huge sprinklers and
has to be really pouring hard even if
you want to make it look like a light
rain it's got to be pouring hard and
think about it when was the last time
you saw a scene in the movie where it
was raining lightly yeah they're almost
aren't any because you can't show it how
do you show just a gentle rain you can't
so every rain scene in every movie I
defy you to find me a scene where it's
not pouring it's always pouring because
that is the only way they can make it
work so that the camera can actually
film it so that we can actually see it
here's another reality in this scene
though or lack of reality and that is
that everything that he has in his
backpack the gun everything is in
perfect shape nothing fell out nothing
ripped off they went an awfully long way
and he managed to throw her pack
perfectly down to where it was supposed
to go yeah it's Hollywood okay next up
Apocalypse Now
[Music]
that's a nice little scene there in
terms of the ecosystem reality you might
be surprised to learn that there's
actually a lot of sand beaches in the
interior of jungles this when you get
rivers you you do get sand beaches it's
just there in places you wouldn't expect
to see them gathering mangoes well when
you're on a jungle river those
overhanging branches you have to be
really careful because that is where you
will find it vipers and different snakes
spiders poisonous ants you name it
that's where they are they're hanging in
those clusters of branches you're going
to be in the Vietnamese jungle and
asking the question if there are
poisonous snakes then you clearly miss
the memo you aren't paying attention to
the briefing it's so hard to find real
fruit in a jungle situation most of the
time you're looking at big fat green
leaves I have been in places where I've
been able to gorge on mangos and the
only way I could do that was they were
the ones that were fallen on the ground
because I can't get up to the tree to
get them I've heard people say oh you'll
be fine you can live off mango or you
can live off blueberries yeah if I'm
there in the season when they're ripe
and I can actually get to them that's
the cat's when it comes to finding fruit
in any survival situation actually I
don't mind this kind of banter I've
never been in military service so I
can't speak to that but I've been in
lots of situations like this walking
through a jungle either on my own but
also with other people too and your
conversation meanders always you just
talk about nothing most of the time you
start to get to know people because what
else is there to do and if you're not
looking at something specifically like a
big old spider or a snake you're just
talking about nothing and walking those
fans at the bottom of that tree are so
beautiful to see up close indigenous
cultures would actually use them for
communication you could go up to it and
kick it boom boom and wait a bit and you
hear someone miles away so they would
actually do that for communication I get
it in the Amazon jungle for example
banging on one of those and then
listening to someone reply from miles
away it's it's that's pretty cool look
at the color on that scene I mean this
is all filmmaking and it's beautifully
shot but when you're in the middle of a
jungle you get to see colors like
nowhere else
shades of things and there's a rich
matte finish most of the time there's
Sun in the jungle you can be in places
where the Sun comes through but a lot of
the times it's a matte finish look to
everything big mistake in the jungle you
don't just sit on a log if I were to
walk outside right now I could go and
sit down pretty much anywhere in the
jungle you don't do that you come up to
somewhere and you look around it you
look under it you look on the other side
of the tree you brush it a bit
and then you like okay what okay good
because the chance of there being a
snake right underneath his ass or ants
that hurt a lot going right by his boot
it's pretty high so little sloppy there
Martin when you've got a predator
lurking about watching for signs is
really important when I was in India I
was paying attention always to certain
monkeys because they would go crazy
whenever there was a tiger they'd start
going crazy
that was my warning sign and you can do
that with a lot of different species so
if you watch what else is going on you
will then begin to notice that something
has changed which means something else
has entered the picture there's one
thing that makes me nervous in different
ecosystems it's big cats when I was in
India it had to spend the night in a
tree because of a big tiger I could hear
it growling yeah cats give me the
willies sometimes the thing that's wrong
with this scene is that the Tigers
attacking from the front cats like to
attack from the back sharks are the same
way in India I wore a mask on the back
of my head to ward off a tiger attack
because it sees your eyes so in this
scene it's a face on facing counter can
that happen yes it can happen but 99% of
the time a big cat wants to attack you
from behind I think the final thought on
on the Apocalypse Now film is that they
they went for an incredibly intense
dramatic presentation overall but but
when it comes to the jungle but it was
it's warranted it's very dark and and
there it has an ambience to it that is
not like walking in the forest in
Northern California
so much more is there to be dealing with
than just you know whatever the
storyline happens to be
in this case it's it's a wartime story
thanks for watching the breakdown with
me
take care